surge across america could come with
some serious political consequences
a liberal msnbc hosts warning democrats
about the potential
for a red wave
if democrats do not fight back what are
the odds of a red wave
they're excellent one of the most
endearing and enduring
uh trends in political science
literature is the thing called the
midterm effect
which is you know more than 40 years of
uh the president's party losing seats in
that subsequent midterm election
and crime isn't the only concern
long-time democratic strategist james
carville
is calling out his party for putting
their woke agenda
before voters yep we pay
such a terrible political price for a
slightly more than fringe element of our
party i think people sort of see this
for what it is and
people are way more interested in their
lives and how to improve them than they
are in somebody else's pronoun or
something
okay so i'll start with you dana okay
all right
so it seems that crime is putting the
the dems on the defensive and
when the stephanie rule was asking that
question i wonder like when she says
what happens if
democrats don't fight back like yeah
against crime or against conservatives i
mean what are you fighting
um unfortunately for the democrats they
don't listen to some of the people who
care about them the most
larry summers who warned them about
inflation james carville who's been
talking about this stuff since last year
and look they
almost lost the house because of uh this
woke stuff
and the rahm emanuel is another one who
they just continue to ignore
um in fact they don't even listen to our
own harold ford jr and i think it's an
outrage
when it comes to defund the police led
to crime waves
the woke education issues have led to a
grassroots movement
in the schools you have cancer culture
you have
the environmental issues that are just
making people feel overwhelmed but
while the crime is now number one and
then uh
jobs and the economy but also inflation
is number two so i think that
byte inflation is a phrase that's going
to catch on
i expect everyone to be using it by
tomorrow
but it's a really issue with that but
and you know and they have you know the
call is coming from inside the house
they're trying to warn you
but you're not listening right right and
you know what
greg biden's answer to all of this is to
go after the gun manufacturers
and you know he thinks that if he does
that everything will be fine and
and yet it seems that most americans
don't agree with that
yeah no it's a it's a fatal mistake uh
for the democratic party there already
is a red wave dana it's the blood
flowing from every city
thank you so it's time for a red wave to
meet that red wave
but what drives me crazy about that
msnbc spot and it's the same thing that
i saw on
cnn with don lemon is that they only
care about the crime as a political
issue
they don't care about the they care
about the victory not the victim
so they're just like oh geez you know
the republicans are really going to use
this against us
why don't you care about the dead people
the people that you claim to
to care about cnn or whatever that
stephanie ruled i mean it
turning this into a team sport thing is
why we got here in the first
place and and so you're looking at four
variables really that the dems have
failed
safety with the defunding education
being again not not trumpeting school
choice as much as they should in
critical race theory the economy you're
gonna see inflation pop up and then you
the societal cooperation which seems to
be
you know fraying because of this cancel
culture so they're really
they're really in a hole they're
supposed to be a red wave when
the blue are in power and there's
supposed to be a blue wave when the
red's in power but i think this is
this is going to be massive unless the
republicans once again
are stupid well in 2022 jesse i'm sure
that
look everybody assumes that at the
midterm or the first term of the
president you know goes to the other
party but now
what greg is saying is it's going to be
even even more exaggerated
uh the but i think americans saw this
last summer when
black lives matter the organization were
burning down
cities and businesses the only reason
joe biden won this election was because
of covid remember he scared everybody
slapped on the mask hid in the basement
made it a referendum on donald trump and
had a lot of help with the big
corporations who
you know what they did yeah so he gets
in there and
it's all about code but kobet's almost
over and that's the only reason he has
high approval rating if you believe the
fake news poll so
once cobit's over in the fall where's
his mandate so kovitz gone
trump is gone it goes back to your
regular political landscape and let's
look at the landscape
he's in the 30s for approval on crime
30s in approval on the border
30s on approval for gas prices and the
rights got a fire lit under him for
critical race theory
so you got a bad salesman with high
crime high gas prices hacking and open
borders
that's not good so harold why why
doesn't the left
why don't they understand or the
democrats that they have got to get on
the side of the crime
victim and stop with all this it was the
same with the texas democrats
stop with the phrases and just get
involved in the issue
i don't disagree with you i think jesse
said something here and a day or two ago
and greg you echoed it about this
professional activist class that seems
to dominate i think
that's what james carville was getting
at for me
what happened here in new york a few
weeks ago when democrats nominated
the top two vote getters were the
toughest talkers about
bringing gang units back putting police
back in charge
and holding bad officers accountable
which is something that is completely
compatible to do
if democrats don't focus stephanie had
it right and your polling data
reinforces it
if democrats lose ground on crime and
immigration are seen as weak on those
two issues
we won't be in the majority in the house
and we will likely lose the majority in
the senate
covet was a big reason to win in 2000
2020 for democrats
the question becomes can you hold it and
crime and immigration will be the two
don't forget right inflation
you take all credit for that hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else